I got a magic trick for you ready I have
to say I'm not much of a magician but
but we're gonna try okay so here you go
here's the cards one from ten of hearts
I'll show them to you so there's nothing
strange they're not marked or anything
so I'm going to shuffle them just
shuffle them a few times okay I've been
I've been practicing this for like three
days three days straight just just for
you just to get this trick ready for you
what I want you to do is just choose a
card and just don't show it to me
so a trill of yours but just don't show
it I'm gonna take this card okay and I'm
gonna try to eat your mind I'm gonna try
to read your mind and see what what card
that is is it the four of Hearts sweet
we're done that's it that's what I
wanted to show you I'm such a bad
magician I'm actually gonna tell you
what I how I did this okay you know I
guess I good magician isn't supposed to
reveal the tricks but I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell you how this works so here's
the cards in order and this might seem a
little bit weird but I'm actually gonna
take the ten out and put a joker back in
and we'll talk about white why I do this
in a you know a minute this is just to
explain a little bit better how the
trick works okay so actually the trick
is very simple I mean you practice it
for an afternoon you're gonna be able to
do it so all I do is just each time I'm
gonna cut the deck exactly in half
you're ten there's ten cards so I put 5
here 5 here and I just make sure that
the shuffle goes perfectly like left
right left right left right so you see I
I go like this left right left right
left right left right left right and
that's what I've been practicing you
know I was practicing on the train on
the way here everything I have to say
without you respect you weren't very
fast at it presumably a good magician
yeah yeah yeah I mean if if you guys
practice you're gonna be much better
than me have this okay but so let's talk
about what I did here okay so you know
we started with the cards in the order
and I'm actually I'm gonna call the
Joker a zero okay just to get it in zero
one two three four five six seven
eight-nine okay so then what I did is
that I cut exactly in half right so cars
0 1 2 3 & 4 on the left and then 5 6 7 8
& 9 on the right mm-hm okay and then
like I said I made sure to just a I'll
turn a left right left right left right
left right this is called a perfect
shuffle it's called a perfect shuffle
and so these are still cards 0 1 2 3 & 4
these are cars 5 6 7 8 & 9
okay and so if I did this right which I
hope I did then when we look at the
cards they should be in the order that
we just did it here so cross your
fingers or cross my fingers zero five
one six two seven three eight four nine
so that's what I did this is the perfect
shuffle and now what I want to show you
is actually a different way of seeing
this in mathematics a very common idea
is to try to see the same object in a
few different ways and so I actually
want to do the same thing graphically so
let me start again with the cards in
order and now let me just draw
graphically what happened here
so I'm just gonna write this order into
this picture so I'm just gonna say this
is the order that the cards are in right
now right yes let's put them over here
so the cards are in the order of this
shuffle yeah zero five one this is these
are the new positions and now what I
want to do is that I want to represent
graphically this perfect shuffle cards
zero state state in position zero right
it stayed on top yeah the card one went
to position one car two went to position
two the card format over here card five
went here and
okay yeah so you're basically seeing
here graphically the the trail that the
cars were taking right here and so this
is kind of a little picture what
happened and here you already start
seeing more structure than maybe what
you would have expected right for
example you notice at the top and the
bottom cards never change positions
there's also this nice symmetry right
you see that this thing at least the
picture looks the same if you flip it
upside down
yeah and that's something that's not at
all clear when you when you do that
thank you okay so let's go back to the
cards so I did one perfect shuffle and
now they're in this order but let me now
do a second perfect shuffle here we go
[Music]
see that was faster sure then I passed
her like that was a different way of
doing this is actually just to follow
the picture right so if I draw the same
picture and just string it along here
then I'm gonna be able to see what
happens to this shuffle so drool that
same pattern again exactly so I'm going
to take this pattern and just transcribe
it directly right next to it okay you
don't even need to look at the cards
that's right
because you know this is the one thing
that I have to be careful is that I'm
always doing the same perfect shuffle
and if I do the same perfect shuffle
then the picture is gonna tell me
exactly what I'm doing and so here I'm
seeing graphically what the shuffle is
doing and so if I'm doing everything
correctly this is exactly the order that
the card should be in okay so now I
wanna keep doing this and the other
thing that I have to do in this trick is
make sure that I do it the right number
of times I just needed to make sure to
do this six times okay I prepared the
trick that way I need to do it six times
now the nice thing is that we can just
do everything at a time so this one is
gonna go straight here this card for
example it keeps going like this
seven goes like this this one is easier
I keep thinking I should make a make a
carpet out of this or something like
that the perfect shuffle carpet exactly
so now I'm gonna make sure to do it also
with the cards so we already did two
perfect shuffles and I'm gonna do four
more
okay so here's one okay here's another
one two four
so the Joker is supposed to be on top
that's not too hard I must have gotten
that right there's the joke okay now
let's follow the path of the one okay so
the one started on top and then it it
went over here and then down here and
then down here over here and according
to this the one went all the way down
and then went back up so if I did this
right and this would be the number one
yes that's part of the two so that to
start up here then it came down here
maybe you start seeing what that's going
to happen right so the card to it went
all the way down and then it ended up in
the next position so again if I did this
right should be the number two I mean
one thing you'll notice here actually is
that if you follow the path of the 102
they're very similar to each other and
you might think that's always gonna
happen but it actually turns out that's
not what's gonna happen so if you look
at the three comes down here and then it
goes back up see it keeps bouncing up
and down yeah so it has a very different
behavior but the outcome is the same
that you know the three jumps down up
down up down up and it also lends in the
correct position so again if I did this
correctly should be right there follow
the four real quick and it lands up over
here okay so card number four and in
position number four so again if I do
this right it should be right there okay
and I could keep doing this but I can
also take advantage of what I notice at
the beginning that there's
symmetry actually this picture is the
same upside down and that means that if
the cards one two three and four ended
up in the right position then so should
the other ones right you know there's a
five
just the six there's a seven
there's the eight there's the knife so
you see what I'm doing is not any kind
of feat of memory or anything like this
is actually very simple
I just shuffled carefully in a way that
when I'm done doing six perfect shuffles
the cards are back in the order where
they started we went like this and then
you took you took this one out and then
I knew that I just needed to come from
here Joker one two three and whatever
the missing one is before that's the
trick
okay that's the trick and you know I
like it I think it's surprising
especially because I mean there's a lot
of possible combinations in in a deck of
cards and it's surprising that it comes
back so quickly and actually after after
I realized this I thought well why does
it come back so quickly only it's only
in six steps and so I thought about this
a little bit harder and I found an even
better explanation for what's going on